I'm Pete Lepage, a developer
advocate on the web team at Google.
In this course,
I'm going to teach you the fundamentals
of progressive web apps.
And you're going to put
your new skills to work
building your own progressive web app.
Progressive web apps are experiences
that combine the best of the web and
the best of apps.
They give users the kind of reliable,
fast, and engaging experience
that they've come to expect from native
apps, but delivered through the web.
They're reliable and
load quickly, even on slow or
intermittent networks, or
when there's no network at all.
They're fast, and scroll,
and animate smoothly.
They're engaging, sending relevant
push notifications to users.
And they're integrated,
showing up on the home screen and
loading as a top level, full screen app.
In this course, you'll learn how
to architect a single page app
using the app shell model which
separates content form the data, and
how to ensure that the app gets data
onscreen as quickly as possible.
Then we'll dive in to service workers.
You'll learn about different
caching strategies and
how to use the most appropriate ones for
different needs.
By the end of the lesson,
your progressive web app
will use a service worker to
cache the app shell and the data.
So it'll work whether your online or
offline.
Finally, you'll learn the ins and
out of how to make your app
installable via the web app manifest.
All of these features are built
entirely using progressive enhancement.
They will light up and be available to
users who have a browser that support
them, while other users will
still get a standard experience.
So, let's get started!